-I also want to talk about
your work husband, Ed O´Neill,
who is such a fantastic actor.
And you know him first from --
-Did you know he was --
he went one time to
the Pittsburgh Steelers, too.
-I did know that, yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I can pretend
I didn´t know that,
but I did know that, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And you knew him first from
"Married...With Children."
-Yes.
-But when you were watching it,
it was in Spanish, and his voice
was dubbed by a Spanish actor.
-Yeah, in Colombia,
we watch things dubbed.
-Yeah.
-But it was --
I think it was, like, dubbed
by some actor from Spain.
-Okay.
-So he had, like, a --
he had, like, this voice,
like an Antonio Banderas
kind of, like, guy.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then that´s how --
You know, like,
once you hear someone,
you grew up listening to that,
the first time I saw him,
that´s what I was expecting.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I´m like -- it´s like,
"This guy doesn´t even know
one word in Spanish."
[ Laughter ]
It was like -- It was a little,
like, heartbreaking,
but, then,
I got used to it fast.
-Yes.
-[ Laughs ]
-You have a new line of --
Is it lingerie?
What would you --
What would you call it?
-Well, it´s not a new line of
lingerie -- it´s an underwear.
-Underwear.
-And -- Yes.
-And it´s called EBY.
-It´s called EBY.
It means "Empowered by You."
-Okay.
And you are the woman that --
sign in.
This is a -- This is
a subscription underwear.
-Oh, okay.
-You receive your underwear
in this little box every month
or every two months
or every four months.
And while you get
this amazing underwear
that is, like, spectacular,
you are donating --
well, not donating --
we are giving 10% net
of the "perceeds"...
"Perceeds"? Yeah.
-Proceeds, yeah.
-...proceeds to empower women...
-Great.
-...through business.
-We´re helping them open
their own businesses.
I´m very excited about this,
because it´s a business for me.
And with my business,
I am going to help empower
other women
to make their own businesses.
So it´s very nice.
-That´s fantastic.
-Yeah. It´s really good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And that´s very convenient
and wonderful.
-And we have all sizes...
-Uh-huh.
-...from not just like, you
know, small, medium, large --
we have extra small to 4X.
-Uh-huh.
-So, we wanted to include
every size of...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Well, they all deserve it.
-They all deserve nice things.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much
for being here.
It´s always
such a pleasure to see you.
-Oh, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]